- On sait que des ministre
sont rencontrés pour en discuter
ce soir, suivi d'une réuni
caucus libéral, mais tout cela
était enveloppé d'un grand sac
de la Selena, lorsque les
députés libéraux ontenenenenenea
raison pour laquelle il y avait
cette rencontre. Donc, une
entente de principe en échange
de quoi? C'est de
avancées dans deogogogrammes ou
des prioritérororororororororore
d'assurance mememements,
programme d'assurance dentaire
aussi. Mais si on parlait
d'entente ncncncncipe, Selena,
ce qu'il faut encore que la néo
démocratieieieie cette entente
et ils sont eux aussi en réunion
de cau'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'n
ce soir.
- cicicicicicicicicicicicicicics
deux parties? On peut comprendrs
néo démocrate?lililililililililt
minoritaire que ça permet uneaua
néo démocrate se font souvent
reprocher de se rapprocher de
des rumeurs des possibilités
d'entente. À l'époque, on nous
disait pour qu'il y ait une
entente, il faut qu'il y ait
suffisamment d'effets de pour le
NPD auquel les électeurs s'en
souviennent au moment du vote.
Donc est-ce qu'il y a
suffisamment un effet wow? Ce
sera visiblement
soir. Il y a une entente qui s